hey a new review as in like a new movie
review for a new movie
from an actual physical movie screening
in a movie theater very exciting but
before we get started i do want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by
raycon raycon earbuds are those slick
stylish true wireless earbuds that
continue to disrupt the industry by
coming in at about half the price of
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market they're slick discreet no
dangling wires or stems
perfect for if you want to ignore people
we've all been there also i maintain
great workout earbuds and summer is upon
us if you're out there camping with your
friends in the wilderness and you
realize hey
there's a lot of down time i need some
music raycon earbuds and as always they
offer six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth powering more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit also raycon offers
their earbuds in a range of fun colors
and patterns and 45-day free return
policy i love that buying with
confidence you know that so click the
link below go to buyreacon.com
john's to get yourself 15 off your recon
purchase and thank you once again to
reikon for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it right now the
hitman's
wife's bodyguard
[Music]
so the hitman's wife's bodyguard is the
sequel to the hitman's bodyguard a movie
that
i'm not gonna lie i was going into this
movie i was like
i don't remember anything about the
first movie which makes sense
recently checked and i gave it the
t-minus rating which goes to show you
when i say i'm gonna forget a movie
i usually do all this is to say two
things one
in order to enjoy the hitman's wife's
bodyguard you don't have to have seen
the first movie
or remember it if you did and two i
enjoyed this movie much more
than the first one first of all what i
like about this movie the cast really
works well together not just ryan
reynolds and samuel l jackson ryan
reynolds samuel l jackson and salma
hayek ryan reynolds and samuel l jackson
gonna have that love hate relationship
that you saw in the first one
i think but also salma hayek being
really crude and really crass i'm like
that's
that in and of itself is shocking and
she did it so well it just completely
works with casting
her specifically granted yeah ryan
reynolds is that character you think of
ryan reynolds in this movie
that's him he's this guy if you cast him
as a character in a movie
you probably know the character you're
getting that said
he crushes it as that character also
this is an action comedy that is to say
the violence is
it's very bloody it's very hard-hitting
and also works with the comedy to give
you some nice hits of dark comedy i
enjoy me some dark comedy what can i say
i laughed my ass off when marvin got
shot in the face and pulp fiction said
anybody who ever watched pulp fiction
ever just the dynamic and the element of
how ryan reynolds gets roped into this
whole thing
again you know you can't just die hard
to it where it's like ah it's just kind
of
chance i guess you can't do that anymore
this movie just leans into that
absurdity it's like ah
well we'll make a reason and it's kind
of chuckle-worthy also you have antonio
banderas being a
bond villain-esque type of villain
character i enjoyed antonio banderas
there are a couple of characters i wish
i'd seen them more
frank grillo's in the movie he doesn't
do much i feel like frank grillo could
have been
a lot of other actors not like i'm like
oh that's totally frank grillo he's the
only one who could do it and i'm glad
happy that he's in it because
i like frank grillo i like seeing him
get work but frank grillo's that guy you
know he's the badass with the gun
whether he's a hero
anti-hero or villain he's the badass one
of those three
that's kicking ass and doing [ __ ] he
doesn't really do a lot of [ __ ] in here
maybe in the sequel i don't know morgan
freeman man he's on the poster don't
look for him
that much in the movie yeah i got five
minutes of screen time
great you put me on the poster i mean
what i understand
he's god for [ __ ] sake not just in
bruce almighty but
actually in real life bruce almighty i
don't think he knew he was being filmed
still i feel like he did more than frank
grillo and as the action is very much
edited to give you those quick shots and
fast pace sometimes it feels jump
cutting especially when you're in a
vehicle you're like uh-huh
yeah we're just we're moving now so
there is that also as i felt the comedy
and the action worked well together
there were a couple scenes one in
particular where the comedy kind of
compromised
the drama or what could have been a good
dramatic moment i mean it's an action
comedy i don't require it but when you
see the scene
i couldn't help but be like if they cut
the comedy out that could have been a
really good character moment for ryan
reynolds character i think that would
have been cool would have elevated the
movie a bit more but in the end i had a
kick-ass good time
with the hitman's wife's bodyguard i
don't know what changed between
the hitman's bodyguard and the hitman's
wife's bodyguard with me maybe this
movie is so much better than the first
one maybe they're both on the same
wavelength and
back when the first one came out i was
just kind of on a different wavelength
and now i'm like oh i can just lean into
that and appreciate it more maybe it's
the times we're in where i'm like i'll
i'll just
please entertain me i'll take it that
that's that's fine that's good enough
but in the end i felt that hitman's
wife's bodyguard is the kind of
action comedy escapism you probably want
if you're going to a movie called
the hitman's wife's bodyguard and the
movie has
this cast movie seems a bit too long in
the sense that i felt like it ended
twice but i still had a good time no
alcohol required all right so the
hitman's wife's bodyguard it doesn't
come out until next week so i don't know
if anyone cares
this week about a movie coming out next
week and i don't know if next week when
it comes out they'll care about a video
on youtube that came out last week so we
will see what happens but have you seen
it what did you think about it or what's
a sequel that's better than the first
movie for you whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you